with this focus on technology low stakes
storyline and relatively graphic pg-13
violence bloodshot is a very different
superhero flick but there's one area in
which director Dave Wilson was clearly
inspired by blood shots higher-profile
pierce the easter eggs in bloodshot the
namesake hero comes by his name rather
simply the top-secret program that
created him is simply called project
bloodshot hey it fits not only is ray
Garrison's blood been replaced by an
army of nanites giving him superpowers
but he really likes to shoot people
that's all so simple but it works in the
comics however the organization that
gives ray his powers goes by a different
name
while one reboot calls the clandestine
organization project Lazarus it's
usually known as project rising spirit
in the first volume of bloodshot project
rising spirit was a secret group based
in Japan and more recent interpretations
it's a contracting group that often
works with the US military and has ties
to the sect a secret society so big that
it includes almost every other secret
society on earth well you know in the
movie the company behind bloodshot is
called rst that's short for rising
spirit tech chure bloodshot the movie
made a few adjustments to the set up the
company is now run by guy Pearce's Emmel
harding for example and it does a lot
more work with prosthetics than it used
to but this is still the rising spirit
fans know and love early in blood shot
before he realizes that everything he
knows is a lie
ray garrison is dead set on taking down
Martin axe the man who he thinks killed
his wife
no Joss
man if you've heard that name and
thought it sounded like something
straight out of a 90s comic book well
you were right Martin axe or often just
axe has been around since 1992 making
him even older than blood shot himself
in the comics axe isn't a sadistic
terrorist or former rst employee he's
actually more of a computer nerd
originally axe was a scion and evolved
human with psychic powers who could
communicate with machines on his debut
axe was a straight-up villain who was
obsessed with getting his hands on all
the groundbreaking tech he could find
including bloodshot's nanites which he
briefly stole later versions of the
character have come down a little more
on the side of a well-meaning rebel he's
out to stop I level corruption not steal
machines that often helps out the
Renegades a group of rebel sigh outs who
fight against the Harbinger foundation
he also often goes by at Sinex because
this is still a valiant comics property
we're talking about here nineties style
silliness is just part of the deal in
blood shot the movie bloodshot looks
like Vin Diesel and some bald ripped you
know the look Diesel is striking but
he's still a normal guy in the comics
however bloodshot is anything but not
only does he have hair but his skin is
white his eyes are red and more often
than not he doesn't wear a shirt showing
off a giant red circle on his chest
canonically the mark is kind of like a
big scar as seen in the comic rays zero
rising spirit pumped the nanites into
bloodshot's body using a giant tube I
stuffed with needles the circle is
basically the mark that the Machine
leaves behind an identical device is
used in the film too but it doesn't
leave a mark probably because it would
look a little silly in live action
bloodshot pays tribute to the heroes
iconic look in a few different ways
though the way that diesels chest starts
to glow red is the nanites and his body
heat up is the most obvious but it's not
the only one even more subtly whenever
there's a scene with Ray on rsts
operating table it opens with a shot
from above if you pay attention you'll
notice a circular medical device on
Diesel's chest right where that red
circle should have been believe it or
not but man without memories who is
repeatedly manipulated into killing the
people framed for killing his wife is
not an original concept twenty years
before bloodshot applied that idea to a
superhero story a young director named
Christopher Nolan turned out a taut
crime thriller called memento that dealt
with the exact same subject
they focused find a pen write this down
and write it down the bloodshot
parallels are obvious but they're not
accidental director Dave Wilson admitted
that momento was a major influence on
blood shots in an interview with the
beat but you don't have to do too much
research to figure that out just look at
blood shots cast list Guy Pearce who
starred as Leonard in momento is blood
shots main villain not that the movies
are connected or anything but there's no
way that's just a coincidence in terms
of tone and aesthetics bloodshot feels a
whole lot like Total Recall Terminator
and Robocop but it only calls out one
80s hit directly the beloved Eddie
Murphy vehicle coming to America in the
1988 comedy Murphy plays a key Crown
Prince of the fictional country of
Zamunda who travels to New York City to
find a bride who loves him for himself
not for his royal title in order to pull
off the ruse Hakeem and his friends semi
pose as poor students and take
working-class jobs
naturally hilarity ensues I have
recently been placed in charge of
garbage do you have any that requires
disposal anyway that's what bloodshot
sidekick Wilfred Wiggins is referring to
when he sarcastically calls himself the
crown prince's amudha oh and by the way
while Wilfred mentions that he has a
very comic book sounding name which
implies that Wilfred is some kind of
reference himself he's actually an
original character who was created just
for the fil sorry
Easter egg hunters you're gonna have to
look a little harder check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]